pas de fond vert aujourd'hui et comment
allez-vous covin vous êtes fou quoi mais
c'est d'un bienvenue aujourd'hui vidéo à
deux avec jordan ça fait un moment ça
fait un bon c'était gymnastes allait
revoir peut-être un fossé le gymnaste le
tour de magie je prends écoutez j'ai une
idée d'un concept que je trouve un peu
drôle qui est infaisable tout seul ou du
moins qui prend tout son sens lorsqu'on
le fait à deux il est extrêmement simple
mais j'ai extrêmement hâte
nous avons aujourd'hui jordan et moi dix
photos de nous de tous les âges de
toutes les époques de tous les âges de
un stade ailleurs de où tu veux sur ces
dix photos se trouvent cinq photomontage
alors attention
soit c'est vraiment rodez ou soit c'est
du détail soit c'est un entre deux brefs
cinq photos ont été photoshopée d'une
manière plus ou moins violentes on va
chacun notre tour se montrer une photo
et l'autre devra deviner si elle est
photoshopée s'il s'agit d'un
photomontage ou pas on va juste compter
les points genre cet automne un point
par bonne réponse exactement c'est ça
exactement simple efficace on aura tous
et d une note sur 10 à chaque fois je
demande un piquet pour le choix de la
photo photo à au coin greg tu commences
je commence bien précises au maintien
donc comment je suis modeste
ok ok regarde par regarde pas jordan
jatta soir viennent s'asseoir avant de
regarder comme ça tu es bien en place
jordan cette photo présente tel un
photomontage ou non il est stressant
sont ces petits jeux de rôles où tu peut
zoomer
voilà bien confiant mais pas trop non
plus tu peut zoomer
[Musique]
c'est toi ça ouais je saurais pas
expliquer pourquoi mais ça me paraît
fake et j'ai l'impression que ce corps
la relève a été détourné mais alors s'il
a été des tourelles a été des tours est
extrêmement bien ce à quoi je vais dire
c'est pas un photomontage
c'est une vraie photo lucas jordan est
en dernier mot hélas comme ça ne
m'apparaît fake mais je vais quand même
dire c'était laisse moi je vous mets sur
une des tours s'est pas fait c'est une
vraie photo rob hadj met fin à son
calvaire
il s'agit ya absolument 0 éléments faut
se chauffer sur cette image est très
heureux à tapas assez courant moi je
suis très heureux commence très mal pour
moi je compte bien jouer
ok je vais au coin ok squeeze all bat
ares qui caresse à autre chose à temps
mais qd aurait croisé des kangourous
à une époque où tu as les cheveux blonds
ce qui veut dire que c'est entre bye bye
et maintenant est ce que tu es allé en
australie non y at il un endroit un
parka kangourou en france je sais pas on
a envie de croire que l'élément
photoshopée c'est le kangoo mais
peut-être que c'est un arbre dans le
fond qui est pas là elle a juste rajouté
un arbre tu vois honnêtement j'ai c'est
pas photoshop et pour moi est sûr de ça
c'est mon dernier mois ci c'est
photoshopée bien joué donc là j'ai
croisé un congo why not tu vois pocket
lucas cette photo que tu as sous les
yeux n'est pas photoshopée c1 walibi c1
walibi c'est ouf mais c'est des petites
un gourou et le parc se trouve un ange
et j'ai vu que c'était pas ailleurs
installé entre miles hyman mais je me
disais si c'était photoshop
c'était incroyable ok mais pourquoi un
partout jordan c'est moi ramènera
gervanne cette image présente à leurs
photos montages déjà elle présente un
t-shirt blanc transparent
ah ouais mon frère on voit un peu les
têtes attend là tu es fou blond mais
faux bilans là où est ce que ça peut
être en fait il est mêlé bien beau se
coucher de soleil
il est vraiment stylé ce monsieur se
permet ces lots remis sur un des
passagers
elle est adorable est-ce que ça fait
possible si ce décor l'impossible givet
instantanément vas-y je vais tenter
allait pas photoshop et vas-y c'est pas
photoshop et cette photo n'est pas faute
h rue leur déception dernier mot c'est
la bonne réponse jean daniel les portes
à geoffrey croissance où l'on était au
mal du monde gt ça elle est sûre
installé sur un style est sûre instinct
lui à cette photo est-elle georges or il
ya un pigeon derrière qui mangeait que
hocine est le bouillon cube place des
alias à s'amuser des anciens commerces
ah ouais alors les cordonniers les trucs
et ils ont recréé une espèce de course
et grotesque attendait ce juriste avait
bon écoute vas-y je prends mes boules
c'est photoshopée le pigeon n'existe pas
si tu trouves ce qui est photoshopée tu
gagne deux points au lieu dans une
petite règle inventé comme ça
complètement mais je veux nommer ce
pigeon ces pigeons s'appelle christophe
christophe pigeons et bien écoute il est
complètement fake arrivé à revenir sur
sa tête quand je m'assois que je fais le
pigeon arrive que ces éléments taipei de
pigeons debate l'évêque jacques villon
il est en mode je mange mais il mange
quoi là y'a rien mais il est bien fait
parce qu'à l'ombre et où tu vois
et ouais mais je sais pas il m'attendait
dans l'oeil pourquoi raconte loth là
dessus 3 2014 15
ouais je vais à universal studios et se
trouve qu'ils font une op pour attirer
beaucoup de touristes il ya quelques
acteurs de cinéma parmi lesquelles se
trouvent tôt mardi
cette photo jean dame existe-t-elle ou
non hausse est due c'était qu'elle
l'année 2014 ou 2015 je sais plus 2014
2015 année à universal des fois c'est
juste la perche qui a été rajouté
dernière pour une paire chambre pourquoi
cette photo présente tel un photomontage
si oui lequel
non non j'écoute ma bien j'en donne
mardi n'est pas sur cette photo
y'avait pas du tout l'événement avec des
acteurs américains et tous et tchao a
remis la photo ah là là ok toi oh je
peux te le dire en tout cas c'est au
bioparc de doué-la-fontaine ces deux
réserves immenses
peut-être quoi qu'il en soit cette photo
présente un photomontage pour la simple
et bonne raison que derrière toi il ya
un lion l'un des animaux les plus
dangereux de cette planète et entre toi
et ce lyon j'ai l'impression ferroviaire
neil vitres et clôtures qui fait 12
mètres pour l'empêcher de venir te
manger directeur donc jardin elle pousse
toi là et quand même réfléchi genre tu
te dis j'aurais des sympas de ouf
gérard était aussi que si tu vas y à un
lyon très rond c'est pas ton genre de
faire cette photo est totalement
photoshopée et je pense que c'est tout
le fond qui n'est pas sur la photo
originale
ok c'est mon dernier mot et grenoble ce
lion n'existe pas et tout le fond existe
assez que le lion c'est que le lion à la
place c'est un vautour il ne se dit peu
des deux à base de jeux ni celle là
c'est chaud quoi d'ailleurs j'ai fait
une vidéo là bas et je suis allé voir
des lions fin on a nourri et avec ordre
doit y avait d'énormes les normes cache
jordan cette photo présente tel un
photomontage ou non il ya un truc qui me
ce qui me gêne je vais dire ce que c'est
c'est ton t-shirt mon t-shirt
ouais je vais encore celui-là non le
migrant es tu regardes dans mon dressing
mais tu es fou
vas-y taux n'empêchera les vrais la
photo est vrai elle est vraie elle a été
fait elle a été faite à l'iphone et des
petits bugs ont leur portrait iphone ça
va jarre dame effectivement il a été
prise avec le mode mobile iphone grâce à
ce que tu as à repérer juste ici mais
les traits d'avions dans le ciel allait
[ __ ] très nerveuse est sérieux là les
traits d'avion dans le site avait dit le
ciel je te redonner deux fois au but
mais ça c'est dans une autre dimension
ouah
un détecte si cette photo photomontage
un mec si c'est un truc rajouter dans
une étagère je suis fini je vais dire un
truc je crois que j'ai direct trouver
mais les gens vont penser carrément que
j'ai triché tellement jeu et parce que
je saurais pas dire pourquoi je trouve
direct ok [ __ ] y'a un truc qui va ce
dialogue
ok mais si j'ai résidents tu as quitté
la vidéo sur cette photo tu m'entends
profil gauche est à un peu la tête en
arrière pour faire le bg et j'ai
l'impression que sur la photo originale
ya pas de masque donc je vais dire ce
que je pense je pensais que sa moto il
faut toujours payer que ce masque n'est
pas sur ton visage sur la photo
originale
est-ce que je suis humilié devant toute
la france voir cette partie la réponse
ce basque existe il est bien sur mon
visage il est dans sa salle de bain ok
jordan cette photo présente elle à
photoshop âge ou non si oui local
clément musique hippie
tout ça pour tout ça pour dire qu'elle
est vraie c'est trop tour d'amer ces
temps derniers mois ouais elle est vraie
je dis bien et ça me fait le même effet
que quand on m'appelait pour aller au
tableau à l'école rappelle toi à
solidays le bracelet il existe me
souviens on avait les lunettes it's ok
ils acheminent je crois que j'avais
vraiment cette chemise là ce jour là
migros a une tête on dirait pas toi on
dirait pas moi me dit pas ta photo choc
la tête d'un des sosies sur ta thèse sur
cette photo l'inspecteur lucas au charme
très loin bon il n'y a pas de photoshop
c'est ton dernier mot
son dernier mot tu peux retourner c'est
bien cette photo est baladé et vingt
regards du public oh non mais non mais
ça se partage et je me suis lavé beyoncé
au premier rang je m'en souviens non je
suis abattu
dommage jordan je vais très arrogant sur
sa loi cette photo est l photoshopée si
oui quel est alors alors tu sais quoi
ça c'est une des dernières collections
de yoko ono band la marge quand j'avais
cette collection cette collection est
sorti l'été dernier je l'avais en avance
ouais ok mais ça l est pas allé par de
récentes n'étaient pas allées du coup à
cet endroit parce que confinement et
houllier qu'ovide mashala non non on a
eu un été tranquille on n'en faut c'est
bien c'est bien ce que tu dis mais j'en
ai rien à [ __ ] lucas alors alors cette
photo tu sais quoi à défaut ces derniers
mois franchement oui
alors cet été là on sort du premier
confinement souviens toi c'est l'été où
tout le monde fait un peu ce qu'il veut
émoi parmi tout le monde aussi je fais
ce que je veux et je décide d'aller à
les endroits où il n'y a pas trop de
monde comme le grand canyon aux états
unis vraiment y aller
jordan cette photo est totalement fausse
j'y suis jamais allée rozès le cas oui
oh [ __ ] celui là c'est horrible
infiltre un stade où il ya un flou
arrondi tout autour la harelle la tête
ajouté après non je pense que c'est sur
le truc original les visages me semble
cohérent
le nombre de doigts et correcte la tenue
cdu jordan le nom de dos mon algorithmes
me permets de te dire fièrement que
cette photo n'est pas photoshop et c'est
mon dernier mot très bien alors le père
noël n'existe pas dans ma vie mais il
existe bel et bien sur cette photo et
cette photo est vrai très bien jordan
ici venez vous levez vous
j'imagine que tu connais et la photo
originale je connais un important
élément je crois très bien alors
celle-ci est-elle la même on présentait
une quelconque modification quelqu'un
j'aimerais vous m'indiquer laquelle
pourquoi pourquoi cette photo tu as tout
à l'heure normale chez que cette vidéo
qui est du coup qui date un peu
j'ai regardé journée la nourriture dans
le cas tu vas t'asseoir parce que
j'aimais réponse cette photo lucas le
toit assis dans ton ancien studio est
complètement réel effectivement cette
image est réelle mais mais ne trouves tu
pas que ce fond d'écran est nul à chier
que cette photo est totalement vrai
éclatée donc on est content c'est vrai
regardez moi cette petite bouille à il
est adorable bla bla qu'est ce que tu
aurais pu photoshop là-dedans bordel
d'ouvrir râpe à fromage
c'était ton délire la photo est vieille
c'est très dur d'intégrer à une vieille
photo avec du gras et c'est un truc
photoshopée ya l'ombre dr toile est
immense mais ça correspond à celle du
flash qu'est-ce qui peut être
photoshopée en même temps il ya un vieux
pieds l'un quel beau monologue il n'y a
pas de face au chômage
s'il y en a un il est sous tes yeux il
est devant toi les devants tôt ces mêmes
l'élément quasiment principal ne dit pas
assez les pieds ça c'est moi ouais ça
lucas c'est un combiné ouvre boîte mais
vraiment maïdi mec lucas le cadeau de
noël
c'est un combiné ouvre boîte râpe à
fromage
jamais on off ça à un enfant
jordan cette photo présente tel un
élément photoshopée si oui lequel pour
éventuellement gratter deux points les
chaussures c'est cool
le winter elle aussi n'a de swing parade
mais réelle je reconnais là ces
expressions faciales
c'est vrai c'est lui les lunettes rondes
on saluerait pas et lunettes rondes ses
sacs ses photos stop elle mais elle est
vraie je vais faire un petit zone est
bon
voilà
j'ai pas de tatouage ici en chine savez
quoi tu vas jouer tu veux dire il n'y
avait pas de calais où l'aca à
l'assemblée ni exactement tout le fond
est faux c'est mon dernier mot à toi
donc là tu as signé que je ne suis pas à
100 tonnes
tu n'es pas à sainte-aurélie je le vois
au niveau du contour de tes bras et
surtout l'ombre autour de tes chaussures
voilà je les trouve étrange peut-être
des chevaux mais c'est mon dernier mot
lucas les mecs j'ai l'impression qu'on
est en finale de coupe du monde ne sait
pas quoi cette photo comme tu l'as dit
est complètement fausse je suis
simplement moi vrai le reste est temps
d'y rêver à quel homme no 2 reprend la
tête jardin jordan
ouais cette photo est elle vraie ou non
[Musique]
[ __ ] c'est le bateau me gène le bateau
que jeanne cette photo [ __ ] mais cette
photo est vrai en fait cette photo est
vrai ces temps derniers mois
jordan j'avais la réponse puisque le
bateau n'existe pas cette fois qu est ce
qu un [ __ ] de catalan vous voterez
mais je sais que tu es allé au japon un
jeu le japon la tt ou là
ah bah je sais que c'était tokyo mais
c'est tellement grand tokyo
et toi tu filmes et là bas tu bloqués
dans les rues là bah ouais ouais ouais à
cette photo est fausse je peux tu me
dire pourquoi crois moi les japonais ils
ont pas froid à gauche il ya un man il
est habillé comme s'il pleuvait là bas
quand il pleut sillage armand du vent
c'est pas agréable et toi toi tu es en
t-shirt avec une caméra
alors que le sol est mouillé peut-être
ai-je écoute moi bien à redire mentor
mais j'ai tendance à croire que tu
n'étais pas tout que jour là ou alors tu
es le mec le moins frileux du quartier
et je craque le faire tu es un très bon
détective de merde parce que cette photo
est vrai thème à calais au lycée en tee
shirt
oui en plein hiver oui non j'ai chaud en
toutes circonstances
et là bas pour moi il faisait bon bah je
me suis fait peur
ouais ouais ouais jordan c'est la fin de
cette vidéo il est pas où ce concept
s'il est vraiment que ce concept on
vient de revient sur les images je crois
que je me suis pas trompé et qui a bien
7 6 pour moi un mec sain ses joueurs
bons choix qu'avait de vous appelez moi
j'ai adoré d où ce petit branche ton ça
fun à fond on se retrouve dans une
prochaine vidéo est aussi bientôt une
prochaine vidéo sur la chaîne de jordan
oui c'est vrai avec un petit délire
musique tient d'ailleurs merci est passé
c'était trop marrant je trouvais mais
très très cool à refaire de foot à
refaire je t'ai fumée à bientôt base et
l'échéance fort la mienne est génial
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]